if you were to imagine 10 years into the
future what might that look like
it's crazy because it's I would have had
a way more clear answer when I was 12
and now I don't know at all what would
have the answer been when you were 12
making music living in California with a
bunch of friends as simple as that
[Music]
[Music]
let's start talking about the newest
music you've made and how the process
has changed for you from the earliest
days of making music in your bedroom
yeah what's new in the way you're doing
it now
it all starts the same still it'll start
in a bedroom or in a house I'm like more
comfortable making music at home for
some reason which change the most is
probably just the fact that I've gotten
older and I've seen more of the world
touring and stuff I'm not just living in
South Central or in Texas like making
songs from such a closed-off perspective
some of my problems are rooted in more
of like a privileged perspective maybe
which I don't fully love because
sometimes I feel like my stuff can be
like kind of self-indulgent in a way and
it might make the audience like not
connect as much as they used to be able
to connect with the stuff while saying
earlier on so I'm trying to like get to
a spot again where it's just rooted in
something that's real was so well
written that it doesn't seem like it's
just related to me how much do you think
of the listener when you're working on
the music as I'm writing I'm not
thinking about the audience at all I
think it's once I listen back to the
song like 10 times I'm thinking about
like how it's gonna fit into a certain
climate or the world in general you know
you feel any kind of obligation for it
to accomplish anything or not yeah I do
I think that like I'm in such a unique
and like blessed position I should take
advantage of it and make sure that I'm
saying something that I think means
something in this very moment you know
and hopefully sit with someone in a way
that I needed music to sit with me when
I was younger I'm guessing that most of
the music that you loved was not made
with that in mind yeah so it could be a
dangerous limitation I think it's really
dangerous and I feel like I make my best
stuff when it's rooted in survival in a
way like I need to make this in order to
live and I feel like even want to make
art in general it's like that's the only
way I know and express myself so that's
survival but living
sentro it's also like I need to get out
of this environment that's survival and
now it's like I said come from more of a
privileged place which is dangerous as
well there's something cool about like
going away for a long time and living
life and then going back and making
music I kind of want to get into that
but also feel like I put myself in the
position where like I can't stop making
music you know and then like when I keep
making I want to put it out people are
used to that as well for me it also
seems like you didn't start doing it so
much with the purpose but more just
self-expression and yeah self-expression
but also always wanting to be like this
big star thing and I think like I go
between the two constantly like reaching
to become one of the biggest artists but
also trying to survive and like express
and sometimes those two shouldn't be
together I think yeah I'm sure over time
it'll become more clear like like it'll
work itself out yes - yeah do you always
start writing with a beat in mind does
it always come from it like will you
hear a track and start writing or might
lyrics come before there's any music I
always start with the music I think
sometimes though like my favorite stuff
I'll write is if I'm just like walking
somewhere and something comes to my head
like oh that'd be a cool song idea her
cool lyric idea and I'll write that down
and find a way to put that into an album
writing or something
does it happen often no I wish it
happened more because it's always my
favorite stuff yeah when's the last time
it happened who you wrote something down
2016 really yeah that's unbelievable
yeah do you think the world around you
has changed you've changed since 2016 I
think I just worry better now and like
music is in front of me and I'm forced
to write something like this of course
can't come to me I'll just keep going
until I get I catch the magic you know
there's something special about that how
often do you start an idea and then
decide not to continue to finish it it's
been happening more often lately and
that's because I think I'm just more
insecure and less confident as an artist
for some reason I think a little bit of
success I've seen how
had a lot to do with that it's
interesting how could go either way like
success could be either wow people like
what I do so yeah I can I'm free to do
that
or it could do the opposite yeah yes yes
exactly because early on I think like
when we were making our first three
albums everything we were saying was
rooted in like just expression because
no one was paying attention
yeah and that those are some of the most
like freeing and like met the moments I
consider like magic yeah I'm trying to
tap back into that and like lose all
expectations and was that more would you
say it was more about good lines as
opposed to the overall peace in those
days when you liked it good lines and
also just making stuff that would make
us happier like trying to impress each
other yeah you know that rooted and fun
that sounds really healthy yeah there's
there's all the-- any ideas of how you
could get back to that we've been doing
this thing lately every friday we'll sit
in our kitchen and invite a bunch of our
artist friends over and we call it
friday therapy and we'll go around the
circle on one by one people will just
say like what their week has been
looking like and I feel like things like
that communication conversations will
help us get back to like the root of why
we do what we do and I recently became
friends with Shia LaBeouf who's like my
number one inspiration and he's been
there every Friday with us kind of like
guiding the sessions which is cool he's
like 10 years older than me and I can
it's nice to be able to go looking for
like hammer you for advice when I'm
hitting walls you know about how many
people in the room like 40 people Wow
and they'll go on for like four and a
half hours amazing yeah I hope you're
filming those we do film them and they
just keep the footage like this you know
no idea where it's gonna go it feels
really safe we feel safe and like warm
and that everyone's cool with opening up
so it'll get really emotional though you
know people will cry laughs it's like
all over the place it's a great idea
that's really cool yeah how many of them
have you done three beautiful yeah
beautiful
we made a song the first Friday therapy
which was cool yeah so while people were
talking this
we're also making a song in the other
room imagining the energy in the room
must feel really good it does have you
ever done anything like that like do you
do that often do you like talk through
things with people you collaborate with
they're like creative partners yeah are
they like really heavy conversations yes
but rarely do we do it in a big group
usually it's more an intimate group do
you think the fact that it's as many
people as it is gives it more power yeah
definitely gives it more power no way
well I don't know actually intimate
conversations I feel like a very
powerful I guess it depends it depends
on what you're searching for and on
Fridays I think we're searching for like
empathy so you're kind of forced to hear
everyone's side and everyone's
perspective and feel for them in a way
like an empathy exercise mmm I just
needed to find ways to think about
something someone anything other than me
even when yeah I feel like making music
is very selfish as well so like I'm not
there for my family and ways where I
would like to be and I didn't have
enough empathy for like my mom and my
sisters you know and I there's a lot of
regret and guilt I got because lyrics
I've written you seen these songs at
shows and people like singing the lyrics
back to you about your family members
that they don't know and to them they're
just characters but to me they're real
people and it's like you know just
creates a space for me to live in where
I just feel guilt did your mom or sister
ever say anything to you about like
lyrics I've written I think so for sure
yeah I've definitely had like arguments
and conversations with them about it
it's a confusing thing because you feel
better after I write these songs right
and it is like my experience it's just
such a I feel selfish thing to do to put
the entire story my one-sided
perspective on display and then benefit
off of it and then feel like I'm not
there enough for my mom
and have you talked to her about how you
feel nope I talked about it in the last
interview I did with GQ and this funny
because I was the the guy I was talking
to about it he was saying how like he's
learned that he has been communicating
with his mom and with his family through
media in a way and through his art and
it's kind of just been like their way of
communication which I fully identify
with yeah it makes it a little bit
easier in a way because I have to put on
like a mask any time I talk to anyone
because I just like it's the only way I
know how to express myself was like to
perform so even right now I'm wearing
like a specific mask when I talk to my
mom it's a different one and I'm trying
to get to a place where I don't have to
wear her mask and I could just be fully
vulnerable and myself but it's like it's
hard thing I deal with so many different
sides with me yes do you ever wear a
mask when you're by yourself I think so
yeah and do you feel like they change
over time or the mess tend to be the
same ones changes all the time I bet
there's some exercise you can do where
you where you have a conversation with
where the inner you has a conversation
with the mask you and you can talk to
each other yeah it'd be an interesting
exercise very interesting yeah you start
with you and you imagine the version of
you who who talks to your mom sitting
across from you yeah and you tell him
something that he want him to tell your
mom and you ask him how he would say it
and maybe that would be a good way
that's a great idea that's a really good
idea it might be fun I love that and and
I think i dont know how feeling maybe
something good will come from it yeah
and ultimately if I I don't know why and
I'm making this up but I do believe if
you talk to your mom directly less mask
it might feel good I believe you I need
to find the courage I guess yeah was it
was always hard for you to talk to
people even before everything that's
happened yeah it's always been hard to
talk to people but it's been it was easy
to communicate with my friends yes even
now it's like I find it hard to be a
good leader in a way because of the lack
of confidence so when I walk into the
room and we're all making music I don't
feel as comfortable I don't know what it
is and then the way I'm pushing them
away and I'm not like really
communicating with them the way I used
to
it's like intimacy issue like I'll let
someone in but not fully and as soon as
like I fully start to let them in I want
to push them away and it's weird cuz
it's happening with the people that I've
known for like almost the past 10 years
I'm trying to figure it out every day I
guess
that's all it is because I want to be
around these people I don't want to be
there and I want to be a better leader
I'm stronger yeah it's just hard that
it's just hard to say how I feel
sometimes so the people I really care
about another interesting thing to think
that comes up for you to consider trying
is I'll compare you being the leader to
driving the bus and everybody's on the
bus and you're driving the bus and maybe
see what it's like if you take turns
have people take turns driving the bus
yeah and you just get to ride on the bus
sometimes and see what that's like that
sounds awesome
could be good right that's not awesome
you can make that happen yeah you can
make that happen yeah yeah is there
anybody that you anyone in your life
that you're around where you don't feel
like you have to wear the mask or a mask
I understand that it's different for
different people
ya know because if even if I'm alone
it's like Who am I supposed to be right
now and it's not like I'm like actively
trying to do it just happens naturally
yeah maybe
rooted in the fact that when I was a kid
I was taught to treat adults a specific
way and like
you know perform in a way in front of
them at least my earliest memories of
knowing like I have to like act a
certain way in front of someone and go
it goes back to that and I've just been
doing that my whole life played
constantly do you remember what some of
those rules were I remember being loud
and being told not to be loud if I was
like a wild color as a younger like the
younger version of myself which I think
I was I kind of like became this more
like a grayish thing that's what I'm
hearing you say is a lot of what's
changing is all happening inside you and
not necessarily due to what's going on
around outside of you so it's really
just self-discovery
that's the the mission is more getting
in touch with and getting connected with
your true self without feel like you're
being told how to be here what to do or
say or second-guessing yourself sounds
like the story you talked about about
like being told not to be loud the
message you got wasn't just don't be
loud it's that you can't trust what
feels natural to you yes exactly so
anything that can get you back in touch
with owning your own power would
probably healthy right when you start in
an idea is it clear whether it's gonna
be for a group project or for a solo
project or does it matter in those early
stages when you're making it if I'm
starting an idea for for a group song
another I'm gonna be a specific version
of myself because I'm the group's I
think I get to like I could just blend
in and like let other people shine it's
not all like about me being like this
vulnerable thing so yeah just depends
and I think I let the music guide me
sometimes the music fits more into like
the world of like what a Brockamp this
song is supposed to be versus Kevin
abstract song if you're in the middle of
a Kevin abstract project
and you come up with a song that you
think might lend itself more to the
group would you hold it aside I did that
recently and I regret it
why because I feel like it would have
been a stronger moment for the group so
I just want to really understand yeah
you thought it would be a stronger
moment for the group so you held it back
or you I held it back because I love
this so much and selfishly I put it on
my own record oh I see yeah so that came
during the group session but you thought
it suited your album or a solo session
but I went in with the intent this is
gonna be for the group record I see I
just can't stop making music it seems
like I don't know if that's good or bad
though what do you think you think like
I think it's good to keep making it no
matter what no matter what yeah
absolutely because it's like you said
it's a it's a form of therapy for you
and you get to really express yourself
through through music it's always
healthy to have that outlet I think
without it I don't know how healthy it'd
be right how less how much less happy
you'd be right so like good or bad it's
expressive and once it's out its out and
you just move on to the next night yeah
as long I think the key is that it's
true in the moment it's true in the
moment that you make it and if you think
of it almost like a diary input you know
it's like this is a moment in time yeah
and it's not this doesn't have to be
forever and we all change all the time
mm-hmm as long as it's a true reflection
of where you're at in that moment that's
that's good yeah how has a your
relationship with the rest of the guys
in the group developed over time it's
gotten stronger as a whole like as a
Brotherhood community it's like very
very tight me personally I just feel
myself pushing a lot of people like out
of my life without trying to just become
a more closed off that feel like a
positive or a negative to you I think
it's positive in the sense that I can
see what it is and talk about it
negative because it becomes hard to like
tell people what was going on in my
personal life or whatever it is I like
whether there's a little feeling
day-to-day another positive to that is
that I could write about that stuff
makes better songs you know better group
songs so you feel like maybe in the past
if there was someone in your life that
it was not a good relationship you might
just not say anything and just sort of
deal with the discomfort of that
relationship like a passive-aggressive
type approach not intentional but maybe
just like me just not I'm thinking more
not standing up for yourself in a
relationship in the past yeah for sure
yeah so now by changing that mmm
it sounds like a form of self-care of
like taking care of yourself in a way
that you weren't able to do before
yeah I guess it doesn't feel like that
though it sounds like that yes like it
sounds like what you're describing and
and I see you or discomfort in it but
the discomfort in is because someone
else's feelings are involved and you're
pathetic
so from it from an empathetic point of
view it's like if you're empathetic for
your mom's feelings you're not going to
be loud but by not being loud you aren't
being true to yourself right right so
yeah it's like finding that balance yeah
you can always be yourself and be true
to yourself
but communicate in a way where those
around you don't are not blindsided by
it yeah where you can just say yeah and
you'll be surprised when you get in the
habit of explaining you know telling
people how you really feel even if
you're concerned that it's gonna hurt
their feelings that ultimately it leads
to a better relationship all the way
around stronger yeah and better because
it's if you have these feelings inside
and you're not sharing them with the
other person
they're going along thinking you're a
different person than who you are so
it's it's almost like a not real
relationship and you're not really to
give you could be sitting next to each
other but you're not really together
because even though you're experiencing
the same thing you're seeing the world
in such a radically different way that
the only way to bridge that is to really
talk through it and it either brings you
closer together or it brings you clarity
in separation in a positive way you know
like it's it's okay that especially over
time I think you'll see that some of
your friends will grow with you on the
same path and other friends will just
have a different path and it's cool and
you feel that clarity that you get after
telling someone how you feel about them
is more important than something like
crashing and burning and it being over
say you have a creative partner get into
this big like argument or discussion and
then the relationship burns you think
that clarity is more important than like
trying to fake your way through the
marriage faking your way through his
always bad yeah it's always bad yeah so
we've never seen a work ever no no it
it's like it just builds like the the
what's unsaid builds a good way you just
described him coming someone what you
think of him maybe that's not the right
wave yeah maybe it's more like sharing
how you feel right how we feel is how we
feel and has less to do with anyone else
it's like people may trigger something
in us but ultimately the response is us
you know it's not they do what they do
it's only a problem if it's our problem
yeah you know
yeah or if you see or if you see your
friend you know hurting themselves and
you want to say as a good friend like
you know I care about you maybe I don't
know you may want to watch that but it's
like I'll miss you if something bad
happens you know right that's coming
from a place of care right and I like
and it is it's all about taking care of
yourself and if you're not taking care
of yourself you can't take care of
anybody it's like that first part is to
you know when you're on an airplane and
they say if something happens if you're
with a baby put your mask on before you
put the baby's mask on yeah you know so
it's like if you you always have to take
care of yourself to be in a position to
help other people what are you working
on now writing wise v Brock Hampton
album just trying to make good
summertime music better choruses I feel
like I haven't been writing good hooks
lately so I'm trying to tap into that
yeah mmm it's better melodic stuff
simple and effective to like I think
that's what's connecting the most with
people right now simple in every aspect
of like the instrumental of the words
everything like just very direct and
familiar in a way could you imagine ever
doing a full project with no rapping
yeah I'd love to
I want to become a better singer though
and I don't mean like on a technical
aspect were like I blow people away like
American Idol style just a better like
vocal performance and I would like to
listen to as a fan I would say as a fan
yeah I really like it when you sing
thank you thanks just as much as when
you rap Thanks that's cool I was a great
day if you were to imagine 10 years into
the future
what might that look like it's crazy
because it's I would have had a way more
clear answer when I was 12
now I don't know though I don't know if
it's because it's rooted in like me
wanting to do so many different things
as an artist or if it's just like some
days I don't want to do this at all
what would have the answer been when you
were 12 making music living in
California with a bunch of friends as
simple as that how the like that's all I
wanted to do ever so maybe into maybe I
want to be making stuff in 10 years with
a bunch of friends I don't know where
I'd want to live though I love
California though I love it here do you
feel like a lot of your favorite artists
continued making music like they just
kept going and never stopped didn't
matter about age or whatever was there a
moment where like they retired I think
most of them kept going out of that it's
what they do and they wouldn't know what
else to do in life right so it's less of
a choice and more about it's what we do
because Andres one of my favorites and a
lot of his interviews he'll talk about
how like some rappers should know when
to stop
as a fan though I kind of want to hear
what my favorite artist is no matter
what it's interesting to see the growth
and like the the change in character and
interested me I think Andre would like
to would like to make me as I can put it
out
you know like he'd like to do that yes
as is dealing with some issues about
around it but Brett wants to when we get
advice from people it's always based on
they're experienced not our experience
mmm you know people are really wanting
to help in sharing sharing their story
but so much of the story is so singular
to them that the same rules might not
apply to everybody right do you think
where you grew up played a role in who
you are 100% I did this thing where I
took a treadmill to Corpus Christi Texas
which is the city I grew up in and I put
the treadmill in front of my child at
home on Brockhampton Street and I walked
and ran on the treadmill for ten hours
straight under the live stream of it and
tweeted out the address so the audience
could come and visit me while I'm on the
treadmill in like while fans are coming
and being nice and giving me food and
pizza and like making sure that I like
I'm stayin good and healthy childhood
friends would drive by their parents
would drive by and wave at me and like
tell me things like it's it's been
amazing watching you grow and stuff like
that made me realize that ya wouldn't be
Who I am right now without being in that
city as a kid or being from that place
so and that's some of the stuff I wish I
tapped into more on my record I think my
favorite part about my album is the fact
that it's honest and genuine I want to
do less overthinking though at the end
of the day I want to be prolific and
have all my ideas just out there and
just move on to the next one it sounds
good that's a good something good to
aspire to yeah and it sounds like it
would feel good to live in that in that
reality
in the case of any particular song how
much do they change from the time you
start it till the time you feel like
there it is
I was making this song oh my last album
called use me in the first version I
made in a day the second I think Jack
the guy who produced the album with me
spent like another day on it so it was
like two days total working on the song
but the one we made in that first day I
played it for my friend and I compared
it to the second version that Jack did
and my friend was like it's there's
something really special when it feels
like a song was just made in the day and
that's it and then it's out I wanted I
want to follow that I want to lean into
that and keep making things there like
just right there in the moment I've
learned that those type of ideas always
get like the best and strongest reaction
from people I think it's because it's
rooted and something that's real do you
feel like something changes through the
process for the better like the opposite
of that stories that never happened yeah
that happens not as often though for me
yeah you ever learned anything about the
songs in retrospect that you didn't know
when you were making them yeah because
when I'm writing a song I never know the
song is about so yeah really a few
months oh my oh that's what I was trying
to say and I'm in no rush to find out it
just feels good to say things sometimes
like it feels good to be in front of a
microphone and be saying a bunch of
random words until like this story is
set up and then that's the hooker versus
set up and do you ever change any lyrics
when you perform songs live yes I do I
do do that because time passes so I'll
say something that's very like in tune
with what's happening currently and then
six months a year later I may not
connect to that line anymore so I'll
change it to something that uh was more
in tune to what's happening do any lines
that you look forward to saying on stage
or any that you the opposite you know
you just feel like I'd rather not say
that tonight I do for that way of it
there's a Brockhampton song called
junkie
I just saw these lyrics about my mom and
about me being gay and like I don't want
to perform that song ever again just
because that guilt I was talking about
earlier you feel an obligation to
perform it are you cool not performing
it I do because I think that that song
you know people live with those lyrics
and those lyrics mean a lot to the kids
identify with our music so I do for
obligated in that sense but if it's not
bringing me peace I don't want to do it
I think some of those things like making
the choice not just not to do a song
that you're as comfortable with or that
makes you feel bad
recognizing it and following how you
feel is one of the things that's gonna
let you do it for a long time it's like
building a wall between you and your
heart yeah have you ever written a song
to a particular piece of music and then
changed the music to the point where
it's not recognizable to the original
thing that guy he started writing yes I
do that all the time that that's how I
finished songs so it sounds like the the
music's that you start with is its
purpose is more as a writing tool than
necessarily as this is how the record
goes yeah it sets up a scene for me in a
way but that the the background can
change once I tell the story if that
makes sense yeah you know so that's
something I learned from you though
anytime I get stuck and I feel like if
the song is just not moving the way I
wanted to we'll just listen to the
acapella just listen to the voice the
vocal play new chords around that see
what it inspires do I suggest that yeah
no I've no memory yeah almost two years
ago that's how we finished a lot of
Brockhampton songs because the issue it
was I I told you that every time you got
to the chorus it felt like it wasn't
moving just well I could just like stay
like that the whole time and not in a
good way
yeah
you know like he'd get bored by the time
the chorus comes out so it's the best
when it feels effortless a change yeah
have you done solo shows not recently no
last time I did then was like 2016 do
you plan on doing any shows around that
car down below
I don't know cuz the songs are so
personal and it's like awkward anyway
just awkward the group stuff is fun cuz
like we're all these different
characters on stage just having already
yes like a party yeah if you don't do
whatever the live version of this album
is it's gonna evolve into songs that
happens sometimes in the context of the
band and and it'll be and it'll be cool
than that in that aspect but it'll never
be the quintessential version of this
experience if you think the group songs
are going to get more personal based on
what how the how the the solo album went
yeah and I'm doing this thing where I'm
trying to write really really personal
stuff but make it be fun so it can fit
that party setting that you're talking
about yeah it's rooted in trauma but
it's not like so dark to where you want
to like listen to it in the darkness you
can listen to it when you're like
driving and like sun's out having a good
time
yeah that's the goal for me right now
it's like being real and uplifting and
honest and all that stuff at the same
time that's the way comedy works really
exactly yeah yeah I'm saying that too
it's like always talking about really
hard serious stuff but in a way to be
able to laugh laugh the energy out
instead of cry it out yeah were there
any particular traumatic events in your
life or was it more of a not being seen
for who you are or not feeling
comfortable with who you are in the
setting you're in was there any like
events or it's like that was dramatic I
think so many different things the most
recent one that is really stuck with me
was kicking our friend out of the group
like fully to me out because it's
someone I've known
I was 14 almost a decade and just like
fully cutting someone off in front of
people the audience it's just a wild
thing something you think about every
single day have you talked to the person
since yes once how was that we ran into
each other somewhere and it was really
quick heartbreaking in a way you know do
you miss him
yes yeah being a group is weird it's
weird it's a weird thing feeling good
for the people you've known for a long
time as a weird thing oh I I wonder what
it was like for like it's one direction
to be put together not really know each
other and I have like history maybe that
makes it easier that's what I'm saying
yeah sometime maybe our [ __ ] is rooted
in like Brotherhood like real family
[ __ ] mm-hmm
have any regrets about the decision No
more time to talk that's it like I wish
that
it didn't make the decision so quickly
even if we made the exact same decision
I wish there was a little bit more time
to talk was all I'm saying and maybe
that's because I just miss how she used
to be so it's like I wish there was a
little bit more time you know maybe that
maybe that's where that comes from how
has it changed the other relationships
in the band I think that's you know
that's probably the thing that has been
pushing me away from everyone in the
sense where it's like I just
it's like identity crisis almost like
Who am I what is this what's the purpose
of this it's funny that your name is
Kevon abstract and you have an identity
crisis yeah it's almost like you wrote
the carrot yeah yeah it's built in yeah
I still want to understand more about
how the relationship between the band
members changed since so you said you
feel like you've lost focus of yourself
and did it start with that event 100%
yes yeah it's made me more insecure as a
leader as an artist question what I'm
capable of creatively even but I don't
think it's gonna stay like that forever
I'm not saying like it's like I'm like
it's over for me here anything yeah it's
just where I am and I'm recognizing it
yes and that's making the work better
for me right now it's making the songs
more true and videos and everything I do
so just stand out saying it out loud
there's a lot for me yeah it sounds like
it it's allowing yourself to go deeper
is music the primary part of all of this
or is it as much about the visuals the
artwork the way you decide to release
music how do you see the importance of
the different aspects of you as an
artist
I'm obsessed with every aspect of it the
presentation is like my favorite parts
where I have the most fun yeah just cuz
I like world-building I like making
something for like me and my friends to
look at be like wow that's cool like
that's like a universe we came up with
aesthetically it's good it's really cool
or like creating characters and then
saying people at shows come dressed up
as those characters that you yeah yes so
cool we would be painted blue and like
have these orange jumpsuits on and if
fans will come to the shows like that
things it's like smallest that there's a
lot for me and then that is all fueled
by the music you know the music is like
the thing that helps me set up the world
visually yeah we did with weave those
characters call them otherworldly
characters so that we know which ones
are talking about okay how much do you
know about them in the beginning like
does it start with just a picture of a
character or is there a backstory it
starts with an image I just I'm obsessed
with images and like things an idea like
an heightened version of one of my
friends like I can if the image is
striking to me are cool they're like
interesting whatever so you may not have
to know what it means I never know what
it means
do you eventually ever know what it
means is it usually yes sometimes
sometimes a narrative can be created
through like the images that I'm
attracted to
the reason we're painted blue is because
I watched this Busta Rhymes video
directed by hype Williams and they were
paint at red and I'll they be
interesting if we were blue so we're
blue but then that becomes like a story
within itself a few more videos and you
know I think I'd be a stronger writer if
like I went in with a little bit more
intent at the very beginning that seems
like the more challenging thing to do
and I'm more comfortable with just like
writing stuff that just comes out
but I think I need to challenge myself
more if I want to be like incredible
really good and have all these like
crazy expectations for myself so maybe I
should follow that lean into that the
more like challenging rap yeah I will
say there's no right way so yeah that
said it's really cool to experiment and
try different ways because you never
know like especially if you if you're
really comfortable doing it one way
trying it a different way will at least
lead to something different and then you
can decide whether it's good or not
mm-hmm especially as you make more stuff
the it can be more about finding ways to
not make the same thing right so
sometimes switching methods switches it
up right can you walk me through the
process of making a song from the very
beginning til it's done every step so
what solo stuff would be me and Romel
who is like my number one creative
collaborator I guess like all the ideas
it's just me and him in our room will be
a we're on tour and we'd stop at like
random studios on an off day middle
America like random places and we'll
just go through musical ideas until
something until I find something I
connect with like emotionally what would
normally its what might those musical
ideas look like simple and effective
chords that's what I was going for a
first just something like a write a well
written course - and on a Brock Hampton
project how would that happen or how
does it happen in the past because it
might be different this time I go deeper
for it and the passage it starts with
like a really simple beat
five guys in the room the mic in the
middle of the room and like us
freestyling and trying to impress each
other one-up each other who has like the
best idea
everyone will lay down the chorus a
verse see what like six the first in
front of each other or do you do them
separately in front of each other we
have a big whiteboard and we'll write
the lyrics together we're like what seek
each other's lyrics and like really
write the songs together as a group
it gets very lonely writing a solo song
it's like it for me because I'm have so
much fun with everyone else I'll sit
with like a six minute demo of all the
ideas and just like jot down my favorite
ideas what I think would be some you
know Matt could have like a 16-bar verse
and there might be eight bars and that
verse that would feel really effective
as like a bridge or altro moment so then
you just take that and slide it over
there and then the song just starts to
get smaller and smaller over time we
start cutting people's verses up and
making making like an intro and outro
stuff like that I'm also into this idea
of the group constantly changing over
time my goal is that one day maybe like
in five years ten years all the members
are there currently on the roster will
be removed from the group and there will
be a brand new group of people under the
name Brock Hampton releasing music so
like we could add a member this year and
then next year add another member and
then like we'll slowly keep leaving the
og members that makes sense
do you ever talk about to me things and
the songs that you haven't experienced I
used to like enough when I was writing
music when I was 17 everything I said
was like a lie made-up fantasy fantasy
now it's uh goodbye yeah I don't really
do that now the worst is like writing
something that's personal and it doesn't
sound good it's like an awkward thing to
listen back to or front of people
the delivery system makes it so good
that you could get past the fact that
it's so revealing exactly so if it's not
working then it's really like
I just you know I just exposed my soul
yeah and it and it didn't work yeah but
sometimes I've learned that I can take
those same lyrics and take them
somewhere else yeah in the context of a
project if you hear one song that's
clearly summer fun fantasy and then the
next one is a really personal heavy song
the personal heavy song might feel even
heavier because you just heard something
that wasn't yeah do you know what I'm
saying sometimes the more every song
touches similar emotions in a project it
can work two ways one they can amplify
each other and the whole becomes much
more powerful because it's like
reinforcing this emotion and sometimes
it does the opposite where it's like hmm
by the six songs like wow like same same
energy I've heard enough yeah yeah so
it's like and again there's no right or
wrong it's just the more moves to the
basket you have the better yeah see
that's what was interesting about
Tyler's new album was like every song
he's touching on the same thing but he
found a different way to talk about it
every song to where it's interesting and
people can listen to it like on loop the
whole time if I issue with write in mind
was I thought every song was me talking
about the same thing and they became
like self-indulgent or boring and I
after hearing his album I'm like maybe I
should have leaned into that because it
amplified it like you just uh for me as
a listener I think they're both great
yeah it's okay I just the one I don't
want to run away from something that I'm
feeling and if I was feeling that for up
like throughout the whole album maybe I
should've just done that the good news
is you're allowed to be self-indulgent
it's one of the great things about being
an artist you don't think it becomes
like like that's about something on a
sick song as I heard I've heard enough
depends how good it is nice trick it's
the same it's like when you bare your
soul and the tracks not good enough it's
like oh yeah it's good it works finding
the way to make it work yeah I think the
first step is recognizing I'm not there
yeah sure so I'm giving yourself
permission to go there right it's part
of it
right should move inside this and some
music sounds good this has been great
cool